well the morning after that historic
indictment Donald Trump is on the attack
we saw this striking image yesterday of
the former president surrounded by his
lawyers in the courtroom where he pled
not guilty to 34 felony counts
prosecutors say the allegations are
linked to hush money payments made to
adult film star Stormy Daniels and two
other people who they say could have
damaged Trump's chances in the 2016
election if there was any speculation
about whether that court appearance
would give Donald Trump pause he put
those questions to rest last night in a
defiant speech at Mar-A-Lago the former
president claimed he's a victim and
targeted the prosecutor and judge in the
case Major Garrett was at Mar-A-Lago
last night and joins us now from West
Palm Beach major good morning what was
it like in the room
good morning John good morning everyone
I got to tell you the atmosphere inside
Mar-A-Lago was festive it seems strange
to say but it was like an indictment
party Trump supporters were eager to
Rally to his defense seeing him as a
kind of political Renegade being
persecuted for challenging the system
the energy and anticipation in the room
were real and then Trump spoke and
despite the history and the stakes
involved the room fell oddly quiet as
the former president read through a
laundry list of all too familiar
political and legal grievances
foreign president Trump portrayed
himself as a victim and I never thought
anything like this
could happen in America and the
Manhattan district attorney who indicted
him a tool of quote radical left
lunatics the only crime that I have
committed is to fearlessly defend our
nation from those who seek to destroy it
Trump said his indictment cast a dark
cloud Over America virtually everybody
that has looked at this case including
rhinos and even hardcore Democrats
say there is no crime during a nearly
half hour speech peppered with a laundry
list of baseless grievances Trump
attacked Manhattan district attorney
Alvin Bragg and the judge presiding over
his case Trump's oldest Sons posted
articles pointing to the judge's
daughters work with then Presidential
candidate Kamala Harris's campaign the
criminal is the district attorney I have
a trump-hating judge
with the trump-hating wife and family
Trump also said falsely the 2020
election was stolen from him he
characterized other ongoing
investigations in Georgia and Washington
as led by racists or Trump haters Trump
and the Republican Party he leads have
suffered setbacks in three consecutive
elections a fact Trump tried to turn on
its head they can't beat us at The
Ballot Box so they try and beat us
through the law I'm here to protest on
the historic day in Manhattan more
reporters than protesters observed
Trump's arrival multiple layers of
security enveloped Trump's every
movement inside the courtroom during an
hour-long arraignment and for his
departure Trump speaking for himself
entered a plea if not guilty to all 34
felony counts of falsifying business
records the charges prosecutors said
arose from a series of hush money
payments designed to suppress the bad
press that might have influenced the
2016 presidential campaign Manhattan
district attorney Bragg no matter who
you are
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conducts Trump's lawyers said
they plan to file a motion to dismiss
the case within the next several months
while everyone is not a buffalo no one's
below it either and if this man's name
was not Donald J Trump there is no
scenario we'd all be here today Trump
has leveraged the threat of arrest and
the reality of indictment to raise
millions in campaign contributions his
campaign sent out several appeals one
offered a t-shirt with a phony mug shot
the next court hearing is scheduled for
December 4th roughly two months before
the first Republican party nominating
contest the Trump campaign said it has
raised more than 10 million dollars
since the indictment the former
president's next public appearance could
be as early as next week when he's
scheduled to address the National Rifle
Association convention in Indianapolis
Natalie
all right major thank you